I was coming from Hollywood from CBS
then I'm pulling out I like I'm going
down Fairfax I'm pulling out you know
cars park on the side like at the meters
yeah this like Honda or some darts in
front of me like who are you and you're
I'm in my Ferrari no I'm in the wrapped
or I have a different story
yeah I'm not my Raptor giant car would
have [ __ ] his car poppy would hit me
but I honked the horn just so I was like
dude you're about to hit me just give
him a heads up like you're about to hit
me
I don't thorn he goes parked his car
so there's red light above park his car
gets out know where I'm I swear I'm I
know hits my hood oh goes get out
[ __ ] like Oh God
are you kidding me so I get out and when
the street and it's by there's like
restaurants and stores so now people are
like look in and I can see some
someone's like oh I hear buzz like buzz
or big brown so I'm like well alright so
they're definitely gonna film it fitting
goes down that's what's going through my
head right now
yeah and he's I'm not five six
um no alongside of 200 oh no red in the
face so so little chubby forty show
mid-40s
oh that's and I get out and I go what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
man and he goes you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
honky right oh my hot date because
you're darting into traffic you almost
hit my truck man I'm trying to be calm
right that's always try to be calm
always try I go you darted in I'm
honking to give you awareness you don't
hit me you just try and get faster
it's a [ __ ] red light what do you
care if you get down it I don't care
again I'm honking cuz you're gonna hit
my car man and what are you gonna do do
you have a dick gun you have a gun do
you have any weapon he was darling
what do you do what the [ __ ] and do
he goes I dare you to hit me I dare you
to hit me I go why would I hit you
and Yniguez takes that step closer I'm
like oh no he goes I did hit me and he
goes I'll sue the [ __ ] out of you oh my
god oh yeah I know you well man I know
you will I know I want to have a good
day and then he gets back in this guy's
like you [ __ ] you [ __ ] I think
that [ __ ] scrub
you need me to be a cop I would have
come around the other side and I would
go like this I would just get up neck
close to his ear and I'm dead you know
I'd do this and I'd go
hey bro he won't he won't hit you but he
will [ __ ] you if he wants why you is
what other [ __ ] people did because I
would like to see you take that guy and
just [ __ ] him a little detail like like
life's not going his way I can tell it's
how's it go just hold me back Tommy
Bahama shirt on is wrinkly interns going
[ __ ] khakis yeah he's in this rental he
darts off i honk yeah it's probably the
seventh frustrating thing that happened
to him and then I get out he's god damn
it
kids I I bet if I was smaller mmm and
I'm not even trying to shame it I bet if
you were to get out there Ben he was
looking for conflict yeah so when I go
do you have a gun like a bullet saw the
giant get out he might be a bully or
just have an awful day in our past
decide to cross so when it's funny
because obviously physically he's not
gonna beat me that's just not in the
coin fake an injury ensue yeah so when I
get out and then it's kind of humorous
kill you do you have a gun he was gonna
no weapon you just know it what do you
do I know we just stared at each other
yes he takes a step closer because now
there's an audience oh I came from CBS
I'm thinking maybe some of the big execs
are there having lunch they see oh
there's that [ __ ] meat wow you're
gonna fight again I don't think they
would ever set just one yeah and I'll
just say I'll parent I was like oh god
here we go man tell you what do you do
and they take step closer cuz I think he
was embarrassed because now offseason I
can physically assault me that's not in
the cards for him that's not the way
this pecking order works so he's like
all right well I can't just get back to
my car look like a [ __ ] so he just real
close goes I dare you to hit me and I
could just tell my god dude
like don't Hollis I want to be like you
want to fake like you hit me and then
I'll like get back in my car so you can
save face what do you want to do then I
know like what do you want to do mom and
I go what are you doing us Oh
I was like oh that's what's wrong with
this town this is such a bummer man he's
just not really I can't back it up
I just felt bad for him then he gets in
his car and he like darts off and you
tell you didn't want to take the right
but he wanted to get out because you're
so embarrassed so it goes right where
it's just death stop traffic and then I
pull out tonight just like now or window
to window I'm just like is it waiting
waiting you'll fear face yeah it's a
parking lot yeah the only time I've ever
do that and his face was so red just
goes oh [ __ ]
the only time I've ever done anything
like that where I was was I've had road
rage beyond was my child was really
young yeah and in the backseat and this
trucker was tailgating me I mean on my
ass would have killed us all
and I kept [ __ ] and then finally I
pulled alongside him I'm trying to
scream at him I'm giving the fan I'm
trying to get him to pull over I was
that angry I was that a comes the kids I
was done but I was she's all red and
then I tried to fire if he stops a truck
stop like I went to all the calculations
I go I'm just gonna come out of it too
I'm just gonna come at him I'm knocking
and I'm not gonna even warm it's gonna
hit me back and then take all that all
the penalties this truck is meant tough
[ __ ] yes but also my child you
know I know but some of those truckers
you know my uncle's in the Marines won't
get any toys find some more that's fine
in other words sometimes sometimes that
doesn't matter yeah sometimes you're
like you're tough it that it's also kind
of stupid though when you do at your age
of no say it stupid am I like even when
I got back to my truck I'm like I should
just stayed in my [ __ ] truck
obviously the guy's tiny looks like
Danny DeVito
but fatter and uglier listen yeah when I
get out let's say he did have a gun I
got a kid
what's the Buster in there or am i doing
the other car like oh god I can't read
what my daughter's funniest thing I was
like you have a gun that made me my two
kids are in the backseat I probably told
you this and the guy I pulled out same
thing there's this car wash and the guy
goes you and your [ __ ] said the f-word
actually but let's just say but you and
your [ __ ] Tesla [ __ ] you [ __ ] and I
love her with your kid they've my
daughter my somewhere in backseat cuz
you own a car wash beat you didn't tell
me no no I was I was I was I was pulling
up to a stoplight
and I didn't let him get in I did I just
didn't see him so he was trying to pull
in to get in line I just didn't see him
I you and your Posse
your buzzy f worker that is fresh that
yeah I just say [ __ ] f-word you called
me the F word oh oh just hit yes I was
like it's a [ __ ]
yeah but also yeah so yeah y'all so when
you drive a test like I know what you
get well that's what he said right
I kind of think Louis when I had and
think one of my tests was white I now
midnight blue stuff you know I got the
midnight blue now see now guys go that
guy looks like he's got hands oh well no
nothing no not no okay so that but now
when they see me they got that's the guy
with don't don't that's the guy with a
trunk full of Uggs no trunk full of hugs
and tennis rackets
I do have tennis rackets but no Uggs oh
I look down go that guy sucks what [ __ ]
no no no well okay but the bottom line
is my dot and I looked and you know how
that is you get challenged and your mind
goes right you're like your thing maybe
I'll you know just force I know maybe I
go and then my daughter said my daughter
and I think this i'm i think this
exactly said she went 11 years old she
goes dad don't respond oh wow
from the backseat my 11 year older
whiter than both of us that's correct
service
let me although knew and saw everything
and I was like I'm so proud of her yeah
that's and then the guy I didn't say
anything I just look and the guy who's
you buzzing baby and you know if you
just go like this if it's just like
that's how I do it I do if you just go
sorry dude they're like [ __ ] I'm never
getting out of my car to fight over our
traffic I don't give a [ __ ] it's very
strong I don't scare best-case scenario
nothing there's no no upside you're
wrong again the only time I've ever had
like in the last [ __ ] seven years the
one time I've had real like straight-up
serial killer rage was I was at Century
City Mall in the parking lot there's a
nightmare and this old dude and his wife
I mean I wait it's a crosswalk they're
far away
speeds up and comes this close to
hitting me my son I have my
mm yeah that's what happens that's what
I got so upset yeah Joanna's never see
me like that yeah I was like take tiger
I'm about to kill two prunes well they
always say that daddy's going to prison
so so um the Jared Diamond who wrote
that book Guns Germs and Steel diamonds
a lot of diamonds they say they are Pele
I say what book should I read how is it
you can start with Guns Germs and Steel
wanna Pulitzer Prize it's about but sure
that you've around a she's a recommend
to me you it's a lot of work it's right
it's a little boy it's a little dry yes
it's like my life he did a lot of study
with indigenous cultures in Papua New
Guinea cultures that had very little
contact with the outside world cannibals
cultures that practice widow strangling
so when you're their husband dies they
strangle the next of king strangles all
these really weird cultures way up in
the highlands and and tribes that have
been isolated for 40,000 years and and
he said that the times tribes will be
really peaceful all the metro know
they'll be peaceful and everything else
when resources go get scarce and when
say there is enough water and their kids
their children aren't ready yet they get
Janice Idol he said that what they'll do
is to justify their their attacks killed
uncle you'll start coming up with
stories yeah that's what he grew up with
look at this no not him no yeah I mean
that's what I know that's what he that's
what he can't pull that back but that's
what he was around he was around those
people and he set off to see where why
why civilization why all these
inventions happen in Europe and not
anywhere else it's a really interesting
book about that but anyway Road roads
engine but he said we said that human
beings what as soon as to were all nice
we all talked about peace as soon as our
children attend I don't have a night to
eat or drink we will kill those people
over there and that's and he said these
are all gonna be if it's my kids
surviving or you you gonna kill you
gotta kill me.unfortunately that's you
gotta kill - bummer you know if you had
a 2-lane tiger and me you're gonna like
what do you think tiger but without even
without a question that's what happened
no not him fine you killed Brian dude
dammit or say Brian
Errol's man
well I don't like what you see what you
just did now I want to stop you I know
you're a tough guy I know you picked C
we did you you're discounting you're
discounting the fact that I got hands
dude I'm peppering your face pop pop pop
pop pop um yeah dude and go on your body
yeah it should a strange traffic we'll
[ __ ] get yeah speaking of sin your
DNA so finally the motto of that story
we should wrap it up is to always kill
each always attack for always home
attack first we talk your horn and yep
carry a weapon and use it don't worry
about the movies yeah the message
destroyed make sure you carry a gun cuz
if someone was that as nice as I was you
might have problems but you're better
off taking the punch and having a lawyer
in your back seat and videotaping
everything on your dashboard and then
you get lots of money
yeah people have their phones up I was
like now this isn't gonna go well then
no matter what that's the one good thing
about that's actually I think one of the
good things about everybody having
cameras on their phones people are way
less willing to do some crazy [ __ ] well
that that's why guys like you hit me
yeah cuz he knows I can't you know I
think though in states where you're
allowed to carry guns
I believe that homicides are higher yes
in alterations that right yeah it's a
problem yeah I got a little problem with
that yeah what can you do when you see
my back I pull myself up like a champ
thirty times while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it's a gift it's a gift